So here's a data collection refer for I
guess the students at this German
University.
That's of course the link to their website.
So we'll bring that in.
And then here they're showing an example of how to use a histogram.
so in to
Plot histogram. There's a
built-in function in our city called hist.
short for Instagram, of course
so it takes in a number of
arguments
so for example you have
the the x-axis
so if we look at the
head section or the the first number of
rows of this.
data set
We have a few white in
this a little more we can see more clearly.
we have
their student ID
their name their gender their age height weight and all of
that stuff.
Okay.
Let's say you want to plot their height in a histogram. So
you would say students.
And then of course you want to read a particular column. Let's see for
here. We want height.
Now how you visualize a
histogram? They're different ways to visualize histogram now. I told
you that there are.
Three ways to to produce a
quantile.
There are quarters that's all percentile. But even even for
the quartile there are different ways to calculate the
quartile.
There are different algorithms. You can choose to choose the to critical quartile
here if you want to break the histogram.
You can choose a different algorithm to use.
to create your histogram
So for this example, they're using the Sturgis method.
Okay, then.
You can also let's actually run
this one.
Spelling mistake. Yeah.
spelling
mistake. Yeah, so this is a very basic.
basic histogram
Okay.
Now, of course if you want to like label the
x
scale
you can add any more arguments. So for example, you can say x
lab equals. For example, you can
call whatever you want height of students.
And this would then generate another.
histogram plot
So now you can change its label.
Then of course.
You can I'm gonna put a light breaks to make this easier
to read.
You can of course color.
You can color things you want. You can colorize you can color.
These Bars in the histogram. So for example would make
with all of the graphs in R Studio. You have the color argument.
So you all for short?
Then we have different colors. They have one two three,
so that's a good number three.
That turns the green. So if you want to for example visualize two
histograms on the same plot, it
can use different colors to see different
things.